this podcast is brought to you by trunk
club I hate shopping with a passion and
you guys know this and I'm honestly not
any good at it anyway which means I end
up looking like I'm colorblind or
homeless this is where trunk Club comes
in which provides you with your own
personal stylist and makes it easier
than ever to shop for clothes that look
great on your body even if you suck at
picking clothing just go to trunk club
comm forward slash Tim and answer a few
questions and then you'll be sent a
trunk full of awesome clothes so they
base this on your sizes preferences all
that jazz the trunk is then delivered
free of charge both ways so you only pay
for clothes that you keep so you have
prepaid stickers and whatnot if you keep
none it costs you nothing it's super
easy trunk club is not a subscription
service which I wanted to avoid there
are no monthly fees also wanted to avoid
that your stylist is free shipping is
always free and you have ten days to try
on the clothes risk free and trunk club
is backed by Nordstrom which means they
have the highest standards in quality
and customer service if you care about
saving time or looking good check it out
a trunk club.com forward slash Tim again
that's truck club.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years I love
audiobooks and I have to to recommend
right off the bat
number one is perhaps my favorite
audiobook of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing
you will thank me to the graveyard book
the second is vagabonding by ralph pots
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free 30-day trial
is go to audible.com forward slash tim
and you can choose one of those two
books the graveyard book vagabonding or
more than 180,000 audio programs so that
could be a book that could be a magazine
that could be a newspaper it could be a
class it's that easy
go to audible.com forward slash Tim
that's
calm forward-slash Tim and grab a book
enjoy
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers from
the worlds of chess athletics
entertainment politics military etc etc
and this episode is actually a workshop
you are going to listen in on lessons in
negotiating not just that but you will
learn about positioning you will learn
about smart negotiation versus dumb
negotiation and of all of the resources
out there on how to negotiate 99% of
them are piss-poor overcoming mental
barriers related to entrepreneurship
what you should charge or how you should
think about charging for your services
and then mock interviews and the teacher
is ramit sethi these lessons are all
taken from a class that ramita it was a
multi-day course on creativeLIVE dot-com
which is one of the fastest growing
startups I advised where you can find
some of the highest def highest quality
and widest breadth in terms of topic
instructional videos anywhere on the web
you will be very impressed and there is
something for everybody so you should
check it out creative live.com and ver
meat is not your man if you're looking
for political correctness but he is one
of the best negotiators that I know and
he is hilarious one of the quotes from
my first long interview that I did with
him which detailed how he turned his
blog into a multi-million dollar
business is quote Indian people don't
get punched dude we don't get into
fights we're busy doing spelling bees he
is a man who loves to speak truth even
when it's uncomfortable especially when
it's constructive he's willing to take
heat for it and it is all in all very
very entertaining I was considering
calling this episode how to negotiate
like an Indian because that's what he
would call it and does call it but it
could also be considered negotiating for
creatives and this is particularly true
even though I pulled a lot from this
audio for myself where I am in life so
there are things you can use no matter
what stage of your career you happen to
find yourself in but if you are an
entrepreneur perhaps just getting into
entrepreneurship thinking
taking the dive into entrepreneurship or
you just want to get out of a trap of
your own making I think you'll find a
lot here especially as it relates to
language smithing pay a lot of attention
to the word smithing an exact scripting
that ramiz and if a particular section
isn't clicking with you just skip ahead
20 minutes or so and you'll find
yourself in a new lesson a couple of
resources that I want to recommend
before we get started because they
helped me quite a lot are related to
deal making and negotiating and they are
primarily books but one article so first
article is 1,000 true fans by Kevin
Kelly if you're going to read only one
article on marketing that is it then
books the 22 immutable laws of marketing
the original edition talks about
imported light beer and Airlines and
what not not the version for the
internet blue ocean strategy and both of
those books really talked about creating
a category of one which just increases
your leverage in negotiating ability
then two on the tactics and strategies
of actual deal deal crafting and
overcoming objections getting past know
which is the real life I would say
counterpart to getting to yes and
secrets of power negotiating or a
negotiation it is by Dawson da WS o n
who cut his teeth in real estate and I
would suggest getting the audio if you
can and the last resources and all these
things can be found in the show notes at
4-hour workweek comm forward slash
podcast and you can find the original
two-hour conversation through meet at
4-hour work week on forward slash or a
meet but the last is an e-book and that
was my dog smacking her head on the
table but never mind that
the last is an e-book called breaking
the time barrier this was actually
authored by the freshbooks team years
ago when I did it with the CEO before
this came out and it was very very well
done and you can find it online I linked
to that this is well before they ended
up doing anything with podcast but for
those who have asked how can i implement
the principles in the 4-hour workweek if
i have a service business or i'm in a
service industry breaking the time
barrier answers a lot of those questions
so i encourage you guys to check it out
and there are a few things in these
lessons that are not relevant anymore
such as I believe the negotiated app and
occasionally remit will say tomorrow or
the day after we'll talk about a B or C
don't worry about that stuff I had to
pick and choose from about 20 lessons to
get to an hour hour and a half so there
are three or four lessons in here take
what you can ignore what you can't and
if you're Bruce Lee you would add what
is uniquely your own you can find
roommate at ramit sethi comm r am i t SE
thi comm and you can say hello to him
and risk being ridiculed if you want to
poke the tiger by pinging him on twitter
@ @ remit ra MIT and that further adieu
please enjoy these lessons and
conversations and idea tear downs with
Ramiz Sethi we're gonna talk about Oh
optimizing your spending who here
believes that you could actually cut
certain areas of your spending not by
depriving yourself but perhaps by
getting a better rate or negotiating
some of those rates anybody okay we're
gonna do a little exercise where people
are actually gonna negotiate maybe the
people on the web they can negotiate
some of this stuff I'm gonna teach you
the exact words to negotiate with some
of the companies you do business with
and we'll ask some of the people on the
web to negotiate and maybe they can come
back with their results actually doesn't
take that long
alright so I'd like to first introduce a
concept called negotiating like an
Indian okay so basically I was raised
since I was like four years old to
negotiate my mom used to take me to
Macy's and teach me how to negotiate
with the Corpse she's like don't talk to
her she's too experienced go talk to her
she does know what she's doing and I
would learn how to negotiate all this
stuff and like buying a car for most
people who were born here it's like you
walk in there you buy it for us it's
like a five-day event we like ate
breakfast at the car dealership then
we'd go home I'm not kidding we would do
this for like four or five days it was
ridiculous but that's just how we did it
as a family so Indian people know how to
negotiate very very well and I wanted to
teach some of this to people here
because it's not natural right first of
all most of us are afraid of using a
phone which is so weird I don't
understand that but we're talk like
negotiating is haggling and it's
unsavory and what if they say no and all
this stuff anyone here have a somewhat
of a fear of negotiating yeah and it
could be negotiating our salaries could
be negotiating with clients could be
negotiating with some faceless person at
a credit-card company but it turns out
that let's say you're just gonna make up
a number let's say you're spending
hundred bucks a month on cable or
whatever okay with one phone call if you
could negotiate 20 bucks a month off
that that's 200 over 200 dollars a year
in savings right for doing nothing for
one phone call the reason I call this a
big win is that you keep on locking in
those savings for years and years action
you do the action once you get the
results for years and years kind of like
when you raise your race with a client
you raise it once you get the benefits
for years and years does that make sense
so that's a big win because you'll have
to keep doing the work and using
willpower you just do it once boom you
get the results so we're gonna talk
about who we can negotiate against and
I'll give you a list of companies right
now because it's awesome in fact I was
talking backstage to to one of the crew
and he told me he just read my book
starting on Saturday he actually
negotiated his APR with his credit-card
company in other words the interest rate
he's paying for his credit card debt did
anybody know you could do that if you
have debt let's say you have five or ten
thousand dollars you can it doesn't
always work but it works sometimes you
can actually negotiate that rate down I
have people who negotiated something
like 18% down to 8% many people are
saving a hundred plus dollars a month
many hundreds if you have a high amount
I'll just negotiate it so let's talk
about the things we can negotiate then
we're going to talk about how we can use
that for our lives credit card you can
negotiate for late fees easy easy
a PR you can do it's a little harder
cable anybody ever tried to negotiate
with your cable company we're gonna try
that in a few minutes
Jim's that's pretty hard but you can do
that cell phone companies anybody ever
try to negotiate with your cell phone
company
yes did it work yeah how oh how well
from 106 a month down to 79 a month
beautiful one $500 a year one hour and
thirty three minutes phone call
the timer was all very good that's
beautiful $500 a year in savings the
next year it'll be even more right and
that's very impressive for one point
yeah yeah run the math Wow so that's
very good and that's the kind of stuff
we can do so I'm gonna show you an
actual script for how we can negotiate
with some of these folks and this is
something that everybody can do to date
all right you can use this word-for-word
script today and negotiate it all right
and I have a whole bunch more script so
let me show you this so here's a script
okay here's what's going on in this room
gonna read it off then I'm gonna analyze
hi my name is roomie Satie I've been a
customer with your company for four
years you know I've been doing some
research and I came across some other
companies that can offer me a better
deal than what you're giving me now the
thing is I've been a loyal customer for
the past four years and I'd hate to have
to switch to another company just
because of a simple money issue but you
know times are tough so what can you do
for me okay you could break that up you
can make it into three or four
paragraphs if you want but let me
analyze what's going on here this isn't
just some script I wrote in my bedroom
and then put it on this screen this
script has been tested with tens of
thousands of people okay it's been
tested with cable companies credit card
companies all kinds of companies alright
and I have well over hundreds of
thousands of dollars in savings from my
students using this stuff it works does
it always work no can it probably work
for you with one of the companies you're
paying yes you've on you're a great
example five hundred dollars a year so
let me analyze what's going on here I
love this phrase times are tough right
it's like it doesn't really mean
anything but it's actually very true
like times are tough okay
like that's your reason for calling up
and negotiating so if you feel guilty
about calling up a company the truth is
times are tough you call them up you say
look times are tough I also like to
focus on how many years I've been with
the company do you know why do you know
how much it costs for a bank to acquire
you as a cost
anyone have any idea a lot hundreds of
dollars sometimes over $1000 that
includes everything from you know
billboard ads technology the person at
the clerk etc you have to count all that
so do they want to lose you for a twenty
seven dollar late fee no they want to
keep you for years so that's why I
specifically put in this and tested it
how many years I've been with the
company also you hopefully you can do a
little homework and you can find out
another company that's offering you a
better deal let's say you're on company
X for cable and you learn that company Y
is offering a special introductory rate
this happens all the time
you call up the cable company you say
you know I notice that this cable
company is offering in your case 100 and
110 they're offering 75 well what are
they going to do we're actually gonna do
a role play right now so I want to take
one person who wants to negotiate with
me you can pick what kind of company you
want you can i'm your credit-card
company i'm your cable company whatever
and we're gonna do a little mock
negotiation right now who wants to do it
no i'm actually nicer than I seem
jim-jim is tough we could do a gym in a
minute that's a very tough one who else
has got something else who wants to
negotiate they're too intimidated you
can keep sitting at your chairs
otherwise I'm just gonna pick someone
I'll just cold call oh ok Yvonne our
champion
all right so Yvonne who am I am I your
credit card company your cable company
credit card okay
how about I just issue you a late fee
for paying late okay okay and the late
fee was 35 bucks okay so hello welcome
to ABC credit card company how can I
help you hi my name is Yvonne my account
number should be there for you I've been
a loyal customer for the last nine years
and I paid my statement online but it
seems to have registered the following
day and I see on my latest invoices a
$35 late fee I'm not really pleased with
that and I'd like to see where we can
get yeah I'm just I'm not satisfied okay
let me take a look at your account that
uh yeah I do see that late fee
unfortunate
it was received past our grace period
and so unfortunately we'll have to keep
that late feet on your account I really
apologize for that sorry I appreciate
that you're trying you're at least
listening to me but I did make my
payment and there must be some leniency
for someone excuse me who's been with
the company as long as I have and if you
look at my track record I always pay on
time I think that there should be some
extra grace in this case I'd really
appreciate more effort on your part
okay okay I'm able to waive that fee
thank you very much for being a customer
we appreciate you thank you you actually
did a great job and I want to point out
yeah let's give a round here positive I
want to point out what you did that was
so great and then I'll give you a couple
constructive things I might change but
honestly it was great I love that you
didn't end your questions with a yes or
no question this a critical mistake
people make they'll say stuff like can
you do anything for me what's the most
common response someone gives you know
what why would I want to do more work
for myself and have to explain it with
my supervisor you said surely you could
do something for me and you also said
I'm really not satisfied that is
beautiful you ended on a statement I
also love that you were not antagonistic
people think negotiation is about
someone's gonna break down and cry no
you were very polite but you were firm
right anybody else noticed that it
wasn't like heated we're just calm I
also threw in a little no and then you
came back at me you say well I
understand that but blah blah blah blah
blah so a lot of times we don't prepare
and we kind of get shot down they were
like oh okay bye I haven't or just like
oh man so you you came back at me
politely you did a great job I might
suggest a little tweak which is I like
to start it off you know a little little
rapport a little friendliness right so
like you jumped it right into it
I was like damn she's here to play but
instead you know you can say something
like I really appreciate you taking the
time to chat with me first of all before
we get into it I just wanted to confirm
how long I've been a customer with you I
have eight years on my own do you show
the same and then
yes I actually show the same so
basically I'm building rapport hello how
you do it
but I'm also laying the foundation for
me about to say hey you know I've been
with you for eight years as we both
stipulated so just kind of make it a
little friendly it's also possible that
sometimes this company will just say no
and that's the case if so that's okay
you can say thank you very much you can
call back another time all right so
there are ways to do that even show you
this new iPhone app I have where I can
show you exactly how to do it but that's
a script it's very simple it's not
complicated but there are some key
psychological triggers going on in here
right times are tough
there's a competitor that's offering a
better rate and I've been with you for X
years all right let's keep going let's
pause there actually for a second do we
any questions about negotiation I mean
there's so many ways this is an area
where you can instantly save hundreds of
dollars a year and it's a big win
because you lock it in once you get the
savings forever Sarah situations where
you would say don't negotiate like I um
one of the things that you came out with
I guess a couple of months ago was
negotiating your rent yeah I'm living
somewhere where rent is like cheap cheap
and I worry that if I were to negotiate
it that my landlord would actually raise
the yeah you guys are living out there
like actually yeah like she forgot about
it so I do have I do have a mini course
on how to negotiate your rent and rent
is actually very it's possible to
negotiate it's a little tough but it's
one of the biggest wins you can get
right so like a lot of my students they
negotiate like a couple hundred bucks
off their rent which is a lot of money
and that's two hundred bucks a month
they're saving for as long as they live
there
in your case one of the things I advise
is like negotiating your rent isn't for
everyone you want it first do a little
homework and I'll show you how to do
that in the course which is about like
let me understand am i way under paying
rent anyway if so maybe I should just
shut up and be happy with it all right
and if I'm like getting gouged or or or
I'm a really good tenant and maybe I
have a little bit of leeway you can
actually do that so if you know that
you're under paying I probably wouldn't
do anything with that
negotiate like what are your general
rules for not negotiating things if you
see a situation how do you evaluate
great question I negotiate when there's
massive opportunity for savings and I
know that there's leeway in the price so
for example if you're buying like a
$80,000 car I'm just using an example
there's a lot of leeway to be negotiated
if you're but if I'm buying you know
like a hot dog on the side of street in
New York I'm probably not gonna
negotiate I also use social norms so do
people negotiate at McDonald's I would
love to but I've never been successful I
just have so you know you got to be you
got to use your common sense but I would
say that most people particularly in
America under negotiating they
chronically under negotiate and the fact
is like okay look the savings from what
you can save for something you might
save ten bucks a month you might even
get rejected but this is two part one
you can actually get big win savings
because you lock it in forever two when
you start negotiating you start
realizing oh my god a lot of things are
negotiable client rates start dates when
you start working with a client or a
nine-to-five job anything right as long
as you can bring value and you can
communicate value to them so negotiation
for me is two part number one the direct
savings number two the indirect benefit
I get from knowing that a lot of things
are negotiable okay yes true my question
is in your script you had you know I've
done some research and I found company Y
offers this rate what do you what would
you do if you're trying to negotiate a
price but you've done all your research
and you found there aren't any lower
prices and you still want to negotiate
yeah first of all I wouldn't lie I
wouldn't I just wouldn't bring that up
right I would just say look times are
tough I just can't afford this I'd hate
to have to cancel right and see how that
works if they say no you say like what
else can you do for me what other
introductory rates do you have going on
a lot of times cable comfortable I'm
using a cable companies as an example
they'll say okay you know there's nobody
else offering a better deal but we have
an introductory rate going on for our
new customers I'm happy to switch you
there for six months or a year so right
there you're locking in 30 40 bucks a
month of savings as well then that
that's not as big of a win because
you're gonna get shunted back but you
can often ask them for what else can you
do
which is kind of exactly what you said
to me Yvonne instead of saying can you
help no what else can you do for me and
let them figure it out for you okay got
questions from the web oh we're
definitely okay
let's start out with Inca who is asking
this from Cyprus what if you do not have
the advantage of being a long long time
customer or you don't have perfect
on-time payment tract how do you defend
your position well start making payments
on time first of all there's a nice
little automation system I know about
you need to be a good you can't
negotiate from a dramatic position of
weakness I mean you could try and I
would say try because what's the worst
they're gonna do to you say no but if
you are not a good customer then frankly
like why would I say yes right these
companies want good customers they don't
want problematic customers so I would
say get get your behavior in order in
terms of making payments on time etc and
maybe over time maybe a year from now
you can go in negotiate but probably no
harm in trying
alright this is a good question from
Brenda and Rebekah Curfman and Rebekah
is in Nashville Tennessee and I also
want to know how do I handle it when my
clients try these negotiating tactics on
me oh yes so everyone's like oh my god
so so you somebody asked who should I
not negotiate against now is gonna be
like me because it will never work
people try to negotiate with me all the
time and actually they have used some of
my the people who work for me have used
some of my own script against me and I
was like damn it here you go you know
what because because they actually added
such massive value that it wasn't like I
was being tricked I wrote those scripts
but I realized they they convinced me
that the value they added was was there
and was real and tangible and so I
actually awarded them a raise this
happen at another company I used to work
at and now my own company however you
will often find a lot of people who will
try to negotiate you and kind of you
know nickel and dime you and I'm gonna
talk about how to handle that tomorrow
we're actually gonna do some hot seats
where I might be the nickel and dime er
and then you're gonna have to come back
at me so tomorrow's the day about
turning your creativity into income and
we're gonna work on that
we're gonna teach you how to negotiate
with clients and what to do if they
negotiate with you that's perfect
because for a lot
people in here who are have standard
fees say as a photographer and are
asking you know what happens when people
try to negotiate those professional fees
mm-hm so that'll be great
yeah and I'll just say one thing and
before we cover tomorrow you always want
to think long term so if someone if you
see someone who is a potentially amazing
client and they just really hate the
setup fees or whatever fees you know you
might you might actually waive them but
say you know normally I don't do this
but my goal is to work with you over the
long term and I like what you're doing
and I see that there are potentially 12
projects that going forward if I do an
extraordinary job the next engagements
they will have to include this that's
just the way I work but I'm willing
because I want to invest in our
relationship to start off here and I'm
willing to waive that fee if that works
for you who's gonna say no to that plus
what have you just done there you just
locked in potentially 12 new engagements
so a lot of people they get too fickle
and focused on that the near term money
I don't take away my hundred ninety nine
dollars setup fee but really they stop
thinking about that the eighty thousand
dollars they can make for later we'll
talk about that tomorrow can be a
Patrice is wondering if you find that
their gender differences in negotiation
women chronically under negotiate they
use certain words that cost them far
more I discovered this in my own
research it's also validated in the
literature as well they'll say things
like I think or maybe they'll end their
tone with an upturned question mark
anybody here do that my salary with a
lot of you taking sexually at my most
recent position I was able to negotiate
it to almost double the initial offer
did we get that on camera but a friend
of mine who thinks that he would get
along really well with you and I
probably agree I sent him my email and
said you know what do you think of this
as far as negotiating like and he
totally tore it apart and I had a lot of
this like with the yes-or-no question
saying can we try X amount and they
would have said no you know whereas he
said let's try this going forward and we
can sort of like talk about it and so
that I think what's really valuable very
good
I appreciate first of all I appreciate
you implementing some of the stuff I
talked about it's easy if
us to all be here and kind of nod our
heads and be like yeah I'm gonna
negotiate and then not do anything but I
really appreciate that you did it and
you doubled your almost double your
salary I'm so happy for you the gender
differences in negotiation are real okay
and we kind of intuitively notice but
it's in some ways it's not politically
correct to talk about differences
between men and women but I don't
believe that I believe that we are
different we each have our strengths and
weaknesses and I know from my own
research doing my research for my course
how to find your dream job that the
women who came in for testing we brought
him into studio they were just they were
just at a very different level in terms
of negotiation and they had these
chronic tells like an upturn tone saying
I think I might do this which is very
common and it cost like as a hiring
manager I looked at my cool that just
saved me $5,000 that just saved me
$5,000 more and you don't want to be in
that position the thing you said about
can we do this
you're glad never I'm glad you actually
went and talked to a friend who was
strong at negotiating so many of us and
never do this right we walk into a
negotiation with a client or with a
potential boss as if like we just go and
do it for our first time like a fresh
dull meanwhile his boss has done this
five thousand times so you're going up
against a hard-nosed negotiator and we
you expect to beat this person without
even practicing once are you out of your
mind
I love that you actually went to a
friend and we're gonna cover negotiation
in detail on day three but your friend
was right simple changes in language can
actually make you five ten twenty
thousand dollars I'll give you a script
right now we're gonna talk about on
Friday but just I'll just give it to you
right now a lot of people when you're
going to apply for a job they'll say
what are your salary requirements and
I've taught this to other friends who
have been you know killed it in there
uh-huh
I told you I'm a longtime reader so you
say like you know I'm happy to discuss
you know finances a little bit further
down the road but right now I'm just
trying to see if this is position is a
good fit for the both of us there's some
variation there that's exactly right now
beautiful now what what you did with
that and we'll talk about this more what
you did with that was instead of
succumbing to
that question many people believe that
if someone asks a question you have to
answer it anybody who ever watch a
presidential debate are you out of your
mind
you ask the question now these guys are
the true true masters at it now they may
answer the question maybe maybe 30
percent of time but they have a message
and they will do anything to get that
message out okay so let me just give you
an example a top performer would never
answer that almost never so if someone
asks me hey Remy what was your last
salary I need to know for the cyber
requirements I would say exactly I said
you know what I'm happy to discuss money
down the road but right now I'm just
trying to see if there's a good fit for
both of us I'm sure you're trying to do
the same thing now what kind of person
would say that a baller someone who
knows I have five other job offers going
on right now by the way I know I'm so
good that I know the money's gonna come
in fact the money's gonna come let's
just deal with that later it's such a
detail and you know what to me it is and
to a top performer it is but to a
beginning or novice person it's not the
first thing they want to do oh my god
well I mean $40 an hour at the last one
so I need any $43 now right they want to
talk about it and when you start talking
like that what do I know as a hiring
manager a very experienced heart I'm
like okay gotcha gotcha
because maybe I was prepared to pay $60
an hour but you said 40 43 I'm like
sweet I just save 17 bucks an hour oh
right so we make these mistakes way back
here never realizing that 80% of the
work is done before we ever get into the
negotiating room let's keep moving on
we've talked about the differences
between theory and practice and I just
want to take a second to highlight that
we did a lot of stuff about negotiation
if you go to I will teach you to be rich
calm slash creative live I got a bunch
of scripts for you okay
and you're gonna see how you're gonna
feel pretty confident reading these
scripts like it's everyone can read in
their room it's great but actually doing
it Sarah how did it feel the first time
you actually negotiated oh my god I sent
this email and you know that said let's
in it and it was like four sentences
long instead of this flowery like I
think we came you know do well together
and I was terrified they had already
made the offer I knew that they weren't
going to you know say no pool hire
somewhere else someone else the worst
they could do was sort of laugh at my
offer and give a counteroffer but I was
so nervous anyone's email in yeah and
it's interesting you did it via email
mm-hmm something I don't normally
recommend but if it works it works well
it was in a contract negotiation that
they were sort of signing the email got
it so but the point even still sending
an email you were terrified negotiation
is very scary now it's easy to sit
around and read these scripts and feel
like oh I read the script that's enough
wrong everybody today can go and
negotiate probably one thing we can do
we can negotiate you know a service
provider that we're paying to a credit
card cable gym whatever these things are
they will change the way you think about
taking control your life okay so that's
what I mean when I say the difference
between theory and practice
all right we'll take let's take a couple
more questions if we have some more I
know we had a bunch in the chat room we
do always have so many questions
absolutely so Claire of RA is wondering
my credit card got sold to another
company in February how long would you
wait to negotiate with them the credit
report shows my history transferred over
and I think this generally the question
of when can you start negotiating with a
company how long do you need to wait to
establish that relationship just
negotiate now what's the worst they can
say no call back in six months yeah
don't wait February to now is a long
time I said just get going call them up
what else love it let's see a question
from Michelle totes photography in
Atlanta how do you answer the salary
question when you're just submitting a
resume say online and it asks for your
salary requirement easy and /a okay but
what you're gonna learn on Friday is
that if you're already submitting your
resume through the front door through a
website you've probably already lost hmm
okay it's a that's a very yeah it's a
very different way of thinking about
resumes most of us believe if I just
send out 50 more resumes maybe I'll get
a call back wrong you can sidetrack the
entire game and and find a totally
different way of doing it okay what else
well I just want to let you know that
Flair's 36 says I just called my gym and
I got them to lower my membership by
five dollars and give me access to all
of their gym facilities within the state
beautiful
that by the way is even the five
dollar-a-month is better than dreaming
about a $50 a month reduction alright
five dollars a month okay at least we
got started now I bet you this person's
gonna call ten other companies today
these companies don't like me very much
all right what else anything else trade
up here is wondering can you negotiate
insurance um general question what can't
you negotiate yeah you can negotiate
insurance in fact if you Google row meet
safety car insurance you will find an
actual script to negotiate your car
insurance that's a big win because
you're paying a year after year you you
basically call him up and you say look
what kind of discounts do you have
available for XYZ and insurance is such
a massive difference in price when I
compared my insurance that I was paying
I was paid on't no what I was paying I'm
gonna make up a number here let's just
say it was like $300 a month there were
insurance ranges from like $99 a month
to like $900 a month
it's a vast range so you can use that
script on my website to figure that out
as well by the way as we continue with
these questions anyone reading who has
used my negotiation techniques to
negotiate lower rates or higher salaries
or higher client rates I want to hear
from the web because we got a double
you're almost double your salary here I
know a bunch of people watching have
used my techniques so I want to hear
from them as well design diva says for
me I'm in Canada where cable and phone
companies have a monopoly that makes
them difficult to negotiate with I agree
with you that how much it costs for a
company to acquire a customer but it
doesn't appear to have enough weight
over here any suggestions of what could
be added to the script for that sort of
situation no in some cases you just
can't do it so move on don't don't sort
of belabor it move on and just find
something else either to negotiate or
how to earn more money or automate your
money so I want to go back to the gender
thing because I find that really
interesting and I think that with many
things in life just acknowledging what
those differences are or being aware of
what you're doing can lead you to to
make those changes and so they're just
to be aware so new growth says does a
woman need to pretend that she is a man
to negotiate or is they or is there a
feminine negotiation style that is just
as powerful and respected in the
business of course great great great
question
you don't have to pretend to be a man
not at all some of the best negotiators
I know are actually women and they use
their unique strengths for example women
smile more they're more personable I'm
generalizing here but I know I'll give
an example of smiling remember how I
told you I applied to 65 or 70
scholarships so I started I wrote pretty
good essays but I started getting these
interviews and I would go in these
interviews and I was like yeah I'm so
good I'm so person and I kept losing
every scholarship interview this it just
didn't just kept losing him and I was
like what is going on and I finally
videotaped myself and what did I learn I
learned that I wasn't smiling right at
all I just I just didn't smile that much
and once I changed that one tactic
everything changed for me I started
getting scholarship after scholarship
first thing I would suggest and we'll
cover this on Friday is videotaping
yourself you're gonna be very surprised
at how you come off versus how you think
you do some women will smile too much
that's bad because you'll come off as a
little too flirty or giggly that's not
good
some won't smile at all it'll and as as
she pointed out maybe with the idea of
being more masculine you can actually
have a nice blend you can be yourself
but you also want to be really cognizant
of certain phrases you use like can we
do X and and be careful about focusing
on the things that are about a
negotiation rather than can you do this
no okay bye if I were to come to you and
say hey I want you to shoot my wedding
or what or whatever what would you say
if you're not a wedding photographer I
would say I don't have the lighting and
a second shooter good good I don't have
the equipment very good right now forget
the wedding example what are other ways
that you've said I'm not an expert to
someone very good I'm not as good as X
good drew we go I don't usually do this
but I'll you know I don't usually shoot
weddings but I'll do it okay like I'm
not gonna be the best but I'll still do
it okay I actually like that that's a
nice way of overcoming that mental
barrier I'm not usually X but I'm gonna
do it we'll talk about that that's very
good what else
no like we'll talk about that later yeah
I know you want to jump ahead your your
the advanced student okay what else yeah
how about I needed I like to do that but
I need a couple more years yeah for I
get there right interesting
so what else I mean clearly there are
other phrases we say everyone just
nodded at that everybody chimed up what
else huh I'm too young 22 years old in a
city with all of these sort of writers
and they're they're not gonna take me
seriously and yeah uh-huh see the
language is so important if I sit here
and just give these slides and say I'm
not an expert
people like okay that sounds fine check
the box move on but when we talk in the
actual words we use everybody's nodding
their head did you notice that did you
notice how when I put this slide up I
was just like and then when I said I
don't have enough experience or I'm only
22 and ones like oh my god what do we
got on the web Ryan is saying I'm still
learning mm-hmm really good okay what
else
tag streak tag streak and jet says I'm
afraid that by doing something I love it
will turn into just another job that's
good that's not I'm I'm not an expert
but that's definitely a mental barrier
whatever Susan is saying I can't
guarantee that I will be as good as
somebody else
I can't guarantee like what can you
guarantee okay very good
I'm Trey Hollis says I've never been
paid to do this before I love it okay
these are so good these are so good
because we're getting way beneath the
surface of the strategy or the mental
barrier and we're actually understanding
what are the words we say again I'm
doing this because I want you to
understand the importance of language
right you could go to a client and you
could say I'm easy fast and secure and
what would they say get out of my office
I don't even know what you're talking
about
however if you say listen I understand
that you know you know I have my own
three kids and I know how to take how
difficult it is to take photos of them
they don't want to smile sometimes
they're irritable the last week I I took
a photo of someone who was vomiting all
over the store but I actually have my
own I've developed my own way of
reaching out to these kids specifically
kids between the ages of 2 and 4 and let
me show you some photos I've taken
this little boy was crying for two hours
then I did XYZ look at the photos we got
oh my god that mom just started to cry
she feels every fear handled see that
alright let's keep moving on just by the
way if I could really quick just an
interesting one Grubbs says I have
dreadlocks down to my butt and people
don't take my parents seriously so that
kind of is is along that same line yeah
I don't look like people think an expert
looks very good very good I mean that
that's actually true for me when I
started off people like who's this guy
talking about money who's 23 years old
you know back in the day and they wanted
me to change the name of my site because
I will teach you the rich frankly you
know to a lot of people sounds like a
scam and that's very true and how do you
kind of get around that we'll talk about
that okay oh look at this I'd feel weird
charging people for something I'd enjoy
doing anyway or in other words if I were
to charge for this I worry that I would
hate it anybody here ever heard somebody
say that or maybe said it yourself it's
super common yeah why should we pay you
right well that's that's a whole nother
thing about freeloaders we'll talk about
that I love freeloaders I love showing
you how to deal with them um yeah drew I
mean I was just gonna say that can be
also an excuse for you know I'm not
gonna charge you because if it's not
good enough then I'm gonna look like an
idiot and nobody's ever gonna hire me
again very good very good a lot of fear
creatives are struck and paralyzed by
fear that they're not good enough etc
etc and ironically they're simply
focusing on this area never
understanding the game that's being
played around the game of the client not
even really understanding or caring
about you being at this outer end of a
concentric circle of you being
world-class technically they actually
they probably I'm not saying for
everyone but probably they'd be happy if
you're here good not amazing good but
you also understood their hopes fears
and dreams which we're gonna get into
deeply Lululemon could have understand
my hopes fears and dreams addressed it
by putting up a sign that said men and I
would be a customer probably for a long
time
but they didn't a video crew could have
understood my concerns by saying you
know by not even talking about cameras
in front of me because I don't know or
care and saying ramita I understand that
you're on a tight timeline one thing we
can commit to you in writing is that we
will always turn around our videos in 24
hours and if we don't I want you to
charge us 300 dollars a day in late fees
boom charge me anything you want signed
but instead people want to focus on
getting to the outer end of the
concentric circle as if that is gonna
make them incredible anyone here no and
absolutely amazing creative world's best
rider world's best photographer whatever
who can't make a dime yeah because they
don't know any of this other stuff stuff
we're talking about today okay so I love
this barrier because it's so weird all
these barriers are so weird but yet so
true and what do we do what are we
actually staying here I feel weird
charging what we're saying is exactly
what your your online friend said which
is I'm worried about succeeding because
then I'll have all these problems for
example if if I if I actually do all the
things for me to saying I'm gonna be way
too busy and I don't know how to do it
like I don't want that because I don't
have enough time as it is really could
you potentially raise your rates so you
could actually make triple the revenue
in a third of the time yeah once you you
know what it's a good problem to have
that's something every creative needs to
remember you want to have good problems
good problems are like too many clients
because you could raise your rates and
cut those out good problems I have are
too many options it's etc so let's not
preoccupy ourselves with things that
might happen down the road which are
gonna be good all right let's let's stay
in the present and deal with that when
it comes
okay next barrier this is a big one I
hate selling myself let's hear the words
that people have used to describe this
yep
Don look like you have one we're talking
about toughness before um it just feels
so dirty and dishonest is press good
good what else talk to me about it Megan
I
I say that phrase like I say I'm no good
at selling myself you know
yeah I'm not and I've had people
actually offer me money and I'm like no
I'll do it for free
yeah very common very good all right I
like that good Kathy this happens a lot
where people would be like oh I want
this thing and kind of similar I'm like
oh I'm I just sent kind of fries okay
anything from the web this did we do
that we had see Guthrie is saying I feel
creepy uh-huh
and Ryan says I hate being sold too so I
don't want to do that to other people
good well if x3 is saying I was brought
up not to brag about myself yeah me too
that didn't work out so talese selling
out this is the weird this is again one
of the weird pathologies of creatives
which is your selling out and I want to
tell you a story about this because I
went through this myself and it was
actually very emotionally gut wrenching
so on my site I will teach you to be
rich calm I started it when I was in
college and it was a free site
I never monetized it for years and years
I believe was three or four years my
friends a lot of them went to work at
Google this back in like oh four or five
they were like hey put ads on your site
you could like make a lot of money and
my thing was like why I don't want to do
that first of all is it going to make
enough to cover my rent that's I mean if
not why do I care second I'm gonna spend
all my time worrying about these
monetization things and all this stuff
and not even worry about what I'm really
good at which is writing and changing
people's behavior so three years I
didn't monetize it all I actually paid
out of my own pocket and I was fine with
that because it wasn't designed to make
money it was just I needed to get this
out to the world well finally I had a
lot of readers I had maybe like a
hundred thousand monthly readers at that
point or something and I said you know
what I'm gonna try something I'm gonna
create an e-book and I created an e-book
and it was like maybe 30 pages and I
charged $4.95 which is so laughable
because one of my most recent courses
was twelve thousand dollars okay
$4.95 and I was petrified in fact if you
want to read what being petrified looks
like Google
Satie 2007 guide to kicking ass that's
what it was called I I was a I was a
juvenile young man and and and you can
see it in that sales copy I'm afraid I'm
nervous
I literally said why am i charging for
this beak and I actually went on to
explain it like let me defend myself
from you Internet weirdos and guess what
happens
people were like yuge this site jumped
the shark you're just oh I see I will
teach you a rich means I will teach me
how to be rich I could find this for
free on Google all this crap and it was
like my worst fear coming true but
people were ordering like a thousand
people ordered it so I was like what
like all these chatterers who are
telling me your your your sleazy for
selling some for selling a five dollar
ebook after writing free stuff for three
years I felt like so unappreciated and
yet there are all these people buying it
it was very emotionally taxing at times
there have been two big emotional taxing
parts in my business the first was for
the first year and a half of my business
it wasn't a blog it was me teaching in
formal classes at Stanford and everybody
said they would come and then nobody
came and it was really tough to go
through that so I started the blog the
second emotionally taxing part was this
and it really took me another two years
to really get my head around selling if
you look at my new material right anyone
here from the web let's just here if
anyone here is an earn 1k student or a
dream job student or a no-stress
negotiation student these courses are
hundreds or even thousands of times what
I charge for my e-book and guess what I
feel way more comfortable charging for
them
I never defend my price I tell you look
this is it in fact I don't want half of
you to buy this if this this course is
like a three thousand dollar course I'm
like you have credit card debt
you're not allowed to buy it and that
the tenor and the dynamic has changed so
much because I've mentally gone along
that road of being comfortable with
selling by the way my revenues are way
higher okay and ice and it's great no
more emotionally
tax tree meat because I'm not even
dealing with those clients you
understand I have been super clear about
who I serve and super clear about who I
don't when we say things like I hate
selling myself it's just like the person
yesterday who said Remy dis Automation
thing sounds great but it sounds like
you're gambling and you remember my
response my response was that's coming
from a place of fear it's not that this
person has rationally calmly read three
books and evaluated the differences in
asset classes they're just like I don't
understand this so I'm scared like here
for all the people that have said I hate
selling myself selling a sleazy slimy
scammy I feel dirty have they ever taken
one class on sales have they ever
studied marketing no what we do is we go
to we immediately jump psychologically
to the worst thing we can imagine some
dude with really sleazy slimy hair
coming up to you at some party like hey
here's my business card
we should talk we should talk you should
buy this and we're like I don't want to
be that guy but that's not real sales
that's not real marketing again my
students my courses are quite expensive
and my students love to pay it when I do
consulting which I almost never do I
charge an extraordinary rate they're
happy to pay it because I was able to
listen connect understand what value
they wanted and over-deliver selling is
almost the last thing I do and that's
what we're gonna learn today let's throw
to the web and let's throw it to
reactions from here as well and see what
people think about that I feel like I'm
completely stuck in the first circle yep
when you shifted from a point of selling
an e-book for 495 to somewhere close to
charging 3 grand an hour for consulting
did you feel like you had hit your
external challenges those other you
checked off those other circles are you
there
took me years to get these checked off
but had you challenged yourself by
learning the things that you didn't know
yet before you transition to saying I'm
this expensive no I went up a gradual
path we all go up look if you
charging $30 an hour you're probably not
going to charge $300 an hour next month
right
you're gonna go 30 60 at each level
you're going to have to understand
different types of clients and you're
going to have to develop your skills the
skills that I have at $3,000 an hour are
very rare that's why I can charge it and
I also deal with a very small amount of
clients who can afford that or who even
see the value in it right but but if
when I was back charging $20 an hour
that's a whole different client base
they want different things they speak in
different words right a $3,000 an hour
but I'll tell you an example I recently
did a small consulting engagement again
I do maybe one or two a year
the money is really not even that
attractive to me it's about making a big
change and I frankly I would make more
money from spending that time working on
my own business okay which tells you
what kind of business I'd built so I
worked with this gentleman who's a
pretty senior guy in New York and the
sales process was less than two minutes
he knew what I do he knew like what I
what I kind of do on a day to day basis
he said listen would you be willing to
come in and talk to my team about this I
said sure I just charged my normal day
rate he said what is it I told him he
said you charged that much I said yeah I
have a very rare skill set and you know
for the right type of client it makes a
lot of sense to pay that he goes like
this okay
send me an invoice by this afternoon and
that was that so that is what happens at
a 3,000 dollar an hour level he's not
debating me what time are you gonna show
up to my office all that is assumed that
that's gonna work but for a $30 an hour
client you're gonna be having agreements
in place you would talk about what time
you're gonna show up how soon are you
gonna deliver this right it's a whole
different thing at a different level as
you move up that value chain you're just
gonna assume that someone who charges
that much is gonna get it done and by
the way I over deliver to him right he
said something to me he said listen
would you be willing to come in a second
time if we need you in which would have
exceeded my hours do you know what I
said
what would a $30 an hour consultant say
no we're gonna have to write that
in a contract i'ma have to bill you Bill
you for my time bill you for my taxi
what did I say of course because this is
about building a long-term relationship
let's not over focus on the 3,000 dollar
an hour thing let's focus on what we do
today and how we can grow our business
it's very different what my point to you
is at each level as you move up which
you will by the end of today you should
be able to increase your rates by 30
percent easily easily you will
experience different types of clients
different needs different language and
you'll have to adapt so when I charged
147 dollars for a product or whatever
that was different when I charged 12,000
it was totally different okay
all right let's go to the web what do we
got and we'll come back to you Kathy I
love what Susan says she says it makes
me think that if I'm comfortable with my
prices I can be okay with them saying no
thanks so good we're gonna talk about
that today yes you're not trying to
serve everybody what else along the same
lines Peter V says just because I
wouldn't pay that much for my own
services doesn't mean someone else would
good so good what else Kathy you had one
shifting from I was in corporate sales
and I didn't give a [ __ ] it might be
like blah blah blah so from moving from
corporate to small business and
something I really loved I had a lot of
fear and I still do have a lot of fear I
care so much about this thing that I
sometimes forget it's a business and
you're just building relationships Russ
is selling yeah you're building you're
adding value and we're gonna totally
change the dynamic a lot of again a lot
of us jump to the idea that I have to
sell someone I'd to convince them of 800
reasons why they should use my services
and not go to all these other cheaper
photographers or writers the truth is if
you're playing that game you've already
lost you have already lost what you are
doing if that if that's your problem if
you go into clients listen up carefully
everybody especially online if you're
going into client meetings and you find
yourself are almost arguing saying this
is why I'm worth it this is what I do
look at me
yeah you could go to the other guys but
this is what I do you've already lost
because you've you've already missed the
entire game of what are your needs of
ass
without selling which I'm going to show
you how to do I'm actually gonna do hot
seats right bring people up and we do
that you've already lost if you're
sitting there debating price okay when I
sell I'm like listen take it or leave it
this is what this is what kind of value
I can add to your life here's all the
people that have benefited I understand
your concerns I understand them better
than even you understand them and they
read it and they're just like oh my god
this guy is like my mother he knows me
and and and take it or leave it and by
the way there's this you know this thing
is gonna close at a certain point so
we'll talk about that you had one Megan
sue Brice was here she kind of spoke to
that and she was saying you know she
charges thirty three hundred dollars for
her portrait package and somebody asked
the question will you know would you
ever charge more because they were kind
of wondering you know could she make
more money and she's like well not until
I feel like I can deliver a product
that's worth more than thirty three
hundred dollars like I mean because she
already felt like she was delivering all
that she could and she was over
delivering for the price that she was
charging so she really pointed she
really drove that point home that you
have to value the product that you're
offering you know you're not some hack
that's trying to convince somebody like
oh I'm good enough yeah so love that
point loving over-delivering
can be what most creatives think is I
need to over-deliver by taking a higher
resolution photo or whatever the hell
you say writers think I'll deliver an
extra ten words whatever it's irrelevant
you could you should be delivering an
amazing product you need to be doing
that otherwise get out of the game but
over-delivering can be things like you
know what I'm gonna include a
complimentary DVD for you to share I'm
gonna include I'm gonna come back to you
six months later and do a photo refresh
for free I'm gonna come to your office
instead of you having to come to mind
because I know you're a busy executive
and I understand your needs
that's over delivery and at that point
you can charge a lot your clients will
love you because you actually understand
what no one else does everyone's sitting
there saying I'll give you five photos
instead of two I don't care you're
actually addressing my needs so so all
of these things are about over
delivering like for my courses my goal
is to over deliver
10 X sometimes a hundred X I charge a
very extraordinary rate but I want to
deliver much more than that as well so
that is absolutely key ok let's take a
couple from the web and we'll move on so
a couple of people have been saying that
they get it but they're just hardcore
introverts and and have a hard time
talking to people I have introverts in
fact I'm gonna do a case study right now
and then we have one introvert tomorrow
who's going to come on this guy he's
amazing he's not particularly the most
socially skilled guy he's even said that
himself and you're gonna see that you
don't have to be mr. extroverted mr.
networking to do it no there are plenty
of people who even work with me who are
just they're very quiet and they don't
get their energy from being around
people but they know how to ask the
right questions and deliver value some
of them are more comfortable emailing me
proposals that's a way to get around
that as well what I'm gonna challenge
you with is the person who said that
they're immediately jumping to all these
conclusions like I can't sell myself
because I don't I'm not so fluent with
words and I get nervous so I could never
do it wrong a better way to think about
that is okay one of the areas of
weakness for me is I get a little
nervous around people and it drains me
so what are my options one I can
practice how many of us actually do that
number two I can go around that problem
by emailing people instead of going out
to meet them etc etc set it right so
instead of making it a total weakness
let's turn it into how do I get around
this how much did you charge huge
questions on charging raising rates and
stuff like that so my suggestion to
people is really start out with an
hourly rate okay this is controversial
stuff but this is what I found to work
for my students start off with an hourly
rate I like to understand the scope of
what my competition charges so let's say
I'm a photographer and I'm or let's say
I'm a writer and my competitors which
I've looked around at they charge
anywhere between thirty and forty five
dollars an hour okay let's just say so
I'd probably try to charge my right in
there around forty dollars an hour not
at the highest end of it but pretty high
why because I'm going to be doing
valuable work that's going to be way
more valuable than
other people other people are gonna be
stuck here in the laborious tactics of
their craft
well my craft is good and getting better
but I'm also going to be doing all these
other things that my editor cares about
like being interesting like driving
pageviews like blah blah blah blah blah
so I don't want to charge it the highest
because if you charge at the highest
range part of your range then people
gave like hey why why are you charging
so much but over time you will actually
often be able to charge the highest and
even higher like Dean or like other
folks who charge even astronomically
high rates does that make sense okay you
will have to deliver value you will be
able to raise your rates but this is a
basic framework for how much to charge
alright and you can find where people
how much people are charging online you
can just google them okay very simple
we'll get back to some of the questions
but I want to work through these quickly
Oh God should you ever work for free
okay creatives want to kill me right now
already and I haven't even said anything
on this slide because they may throw
around words like spec work is evil oh
my god you're destroying and keeping the
man down blah blah blah blah you don't
know what you're talking about
okay free work can work strategically
you do not want to go around to everyone
and be like yeah I'll work for free
because you're gonna devalue yourself
and you're gonna devalue and who cares
about devaluing at feel you're gonna
devalue yourself alright it's not a
political discussion we're talking about
ourselves in our business here however
free work works when done correctly I
know because I've done it and it has
dramatically accelerated my career and
many of the people who work for me works
for me for free
this is early on and I ended up hiring
them and they've been paid lots of money
so when do you do free and when do you
not you do free if you can ascertain
that the person you're trying to work
with has some characteristics like they
are massively influential like for
example a New York Times columnist who
has connections everywhere or a blogger
with 500,000 readers a month okay or an
author I'm not trying to say come work
for me for free I don't want anybody who
pitch me right now but there are a lot
of people or like a really famous
photographer in your field but what do
you do when you work for them for free
you don't want to just say I'm gonna
work for you for free forever you say
listen I'm
huge fan of what you're doing I really
like the new magazine that you're
building my normal rate is actually $55
an hour but I'm such a fan of what
you're doing that I'd like to build a
portfolio and I want to help you grow
this magazine especially with your
launch in the next one month so if
you're willing I'll be more than happy
to actually do this project for free
with the understanding that once we're
done you give me three referrals to
other people you know or with the
understanding that if I do an
extraordinary job we go back to my
normal rate okay so what happened there
I told them what my normal rate is I
said I'm willing to work for free under
these conditions in other words I'm
taking the power I'm not letting this
guy some freeloading guy tell me oh
you're just a writer you're working for
free never I would never do that but I
would take the power in the relationship
and say you know what I'm willing to
work for free because I need XYZ I need
a portfolio piece I need a
recommendation from you I need this if
you're willing to agree to that I'll be
more than happy to do it does that make
sense is that surprising anybody wanted
doing death threats out there well we
got there were a lot of people who were
just laughing when you said should you
work for free but then people were
saying like I've done it for nonprofits
that I previously selected only if it's
worth something to you in the long run
in exchange for referrals
I do trades great very good all these
things are great notice that the people
who complain about free work and SPAC
work they don't even understand how this
works they're all complaining about this
game but they don't understand the game
is sometimes if you need like if you're
finding that your clients don't trust
you because you have no portfolio you
have to do whatever it takes to get it
portfolio and that might mean working
for free for one or two clients doing an
amazing job and now you have your
portfolio and you're off to the races
right comment sorry about yeah so I did
success I didn't failure with this and a
success of it so I'm a massage therapy
business when I first started I was all
nervous I'm like what am i doing and I
would give things away for free
completely be evaluated lost so much
money took so long to raise my rates etc
so starting that business now I'm
transitioning to kind of helping people
with their marketing and creative
project
and I've worked for free for a year for
my mentor and advisor that has led to a
portfolio of a great site and a great
start and but he connected me with a
political strategist and then this job
came up with a company and because I had
this team and worked for free in this
portfolio I now had a decent proposal
you know I could be in the game and in
the conversation for a new field
beautiful which is outside of that other
one beautiful so I think it's totally
worth it you're working step by step I
love that when I was doing research at
the persuasive technology lab my
professor said to me do you want to take
this for credit or for pay and I said to
him what do you suggest
and he said honestly I would take it for
credit because if you do it for pay then
I'm just gonna have to give you a bunch
of menial work to do but if you do for
credit I'm gonna actually teach you a
lot of stuff that really shaped the way
I thought about it there are more
valuable things than money in the
short-term way more so really think
about it and another guy who ended up
working for me helping with my book
launch guy named Charlie hone he came to
me and he pitched me all these things he
was like hey I think that your videos
could be improved in fact I already did
it here you go take a look at this video
now why did he do that would he do that
for everyone no he knew that I was about
to have a major book launch he knew that
I would probably have connections to
other people and indeed I sent him so
much business he didn't even know what
to do with it so you want to work
strategically with the right people not
always for free but in certain cases it
can make sense alright let's keep going
and if anyone has any questions think of
them now because we'll have about five
minutes for questions at the end of
today and of course we're gonna be back
here tomorrow alright so I believe this
is the last one here how to go from one
client to many or three clients to me
whatever one thing I like to do is a
referral strategy right when when I
agree notice that I'm taking a lot of
concessions from the client because if
I'm a top performer I'm like alright
fine I'll work with you but you have to
agree to a couple things to work with me
that's what a top performer does now
you're not being condescending about it
you're being really polite you say
listen one thing I do is I just want to
see if this worked for you but whenever
I work with a client I make an agreement
that if I do an extraordinary job they
you refer me to three people at the end
does that work for you and of course
they're gonna say yes because you're
first that you have to do an
extraordinary job you actually holding
yourself to a higher standard and then
you're getting referrals at the end the
other thing is remember when we did the
ask without selling technique so I've
liked interview 20 moms or 30 people who
want personal organizers I didn't sell
them on anything I stay in touch with
them I have a little template of email
stuff like that and at the end I might
say listen I'm starting I actually
decided based on what you told me and
you recommended I talked to sue that I
think I really want to do this personal
organizing thing so I'm actually
launching a service I'm probably gonna
put up a website in a couple days but do
you know anyone I should talk to anyone
that might be interested in in
discussing you know having a personal
organiser well if you do that to 20
people how many referrals do you think
you're gonna get a lot so these are easy
ways to go from three or four clients to
many many many more Dean talked about it
in detail we cover it in detail earn 1k
basically if you have clients you
already have a goldmine to go forward
with you can ask them how they found you
what sites do they read where do they go
and then you go there and you present
yourself mica is wondering when asking
for referrals do you ask these clients
to talk to the potential clients first
or do you cold call these referrals
based on the referral itself well that's
a good question
if they're willing to do it say you
always want to respect the client right
so you say what would you prefer would
you prefer to send an introductory email
I can actually write it for you if you
want or would you prefer that I just use
your name when I reach out to them the
clients probably busy so whatever they
want is what you do okay a question from
Adrian Farr in England how do you
research what your competitors are
charging when many of them do not
discuss their prices until they're
trying to close a sale I mean if you
know your market it sounds like you
don't really know your market well and
it's that's very very relevant for a
photographer yeah there are places if
you know your market you're gonna you're
gonna have friends who are in the market
who are gossiping about this stuff all
the time
you're gonna see it in blogs or forums
you're also gonna just have friends who
have personal relationships are like man
did you hear what they closed that deal
for that's a great way to do it you know
the other
thing is you want mentors so mentors and
advisors or something we'll talk about
tomorrow
those people are deeply connected to the
field you might be starting out they've
been in the field for 20 years you're
like listen I'm really stuck what are
people try I don't understand how to
think about my pricing they'll be able
to tell you because they have their
finger on the pulse so someone comes to
me and they asked me about pricing in a
specific area I will in it's an area I
know I'll be able to tell them because
I'm deeply in that market so getting
advisors and mentors beyond
relationships is critical that's great
see the design is wondering what about
if I charged a certain amount and booked
a bride and then eight months later I
doubled my prices the bride referred me
to another prospective bride and told
her how much she chucks she paid do I
give her my new prices or the prices
that I gave to the original bride new
prices but you have to explain why you
can't just jack up your prices to be
like that's how it goes you say listen I
appreciate you reaching out to me I had
an amazing time shooting the wedding
with April and John remember you're not
jumping into pricing immediately too
many creatives are jumping into pricing
pricing is like the last thing and if
you do it right like like the kiss
everything has already been done it's
been done right
the kiss is almost like you know it's
like it's already been decided it's not
even a thing so you're if you're
concerned about pricing my guess is
you're messing it all up over here
you're not connecting you're doing
commodity stuff you're rambling about
yourself but you also need to explain
why and she of course she's gonna be a
long wait a minute I thought you charged
three grand you're charging me six grand
say well I've actually grown my business
since then since then I've added three
additional services because if you're
charging double you need to be adding
more value so one of the things that
you'd be getting that's new is XY and Z
and I'm also happy to do this as a
complementary service to you remember if
you have that much margin you can throw
in a little bit of bonus you know sort
of bonus material for free all right oh
we have a question in the audience yeah
tag question to that in photography
there are a lot of clients who are
solely price driven and they may have
looked at your web presence blog website
Facebook whatever but when they come to
you they asked wedding or portrait or
something but they go directly in for
the price kill
how do you take them back to the first
case I don't do where these clients
people do that to me sometimes - I mean
first of all you probably not conveyed
value on your website
second you've probably had them email
you are the first email saying like how
much you cost hi we looked at your site
we're interested in what your prices are
yeah their price shopping and if you
want to be that service provider then
you can answer them if not you say you
know what like this is what top
performers who charge really high prices
will do they'll say well I really need
to understand your needs first and they
don't just say that to back you off they
actually want to know like what what
kind of wedding do you want are you you
know and senator senators if you just
answer their question like you're not
you're not doing them a service but also
I'm really comfortable like people will
ask me that
and I actually say to them if price is
your first question this probably isn't
right for you but then again that's all
part of it's very congruent with how I
am right like I'll just call people out
and they know that so if someone comes
to me in the first questions about price
I know they're not gonna buy I know it
because if you simply look at my price
you're like wait a minute I could I
could get something similar for 1/10 the
price but you can't get the value so
there are price shoppers you got to be
really careful about simply answering
them you want to ask them why what are
your needs etc and if you find out their
needs you're like I'm just looking
around for the cheapest price well you
know what I really appreciate that but
I'm probably not the right photographer
for you that depends some people do some
people don't if you're charging a super
premium price you will discover that
many or most providers don't alright if
you have price it's really easy to
compare you know I don't understand what
the difference is between $400 here at
200 or how can I I'm just a client I
don't know I don't live in your world
and it's your job to teach me not my job
my job is to simply compare like a menu
who's got a lower price that's what I
think but your job is to show me the
aspirational site the experience why you
understand me better than anyone else
okay okay I can actually back you up on
that I'm currently wearing shoes that
are about three times what I had planned
to pay for shoes and I went to buy some
but before I tried them on
like we didn't talk about price the guy
just grabbed some was I can't put these
on walk around in him and I looked at
them I love them and I walked out
literally
anyway okay so next question is from
dc-3 for hourly consulting is it better
to price in packages and let people
cancel at any time then simply to price
hourly to start with I like to start
hourly I know this is controversial but
I like to start out early because it's
really simple like with Dean you start
at 30 and you just can quickly find out
the market will tell you if you're
reaching out most most people actually
most creatives don't reach out enough
they're like oh well I reached out to
two people I'm like try 10 xìng that try
reaching out to 20 people a week and the
market will quickly tell you if you're
pricing right or not it'll quickly tell
you stuff like you know are people
actually listening to me are they are
the words I'm using resonating so I like
the hourly thing once you nail that
hourly thing once you nail it you know
like I'm in my sweet spot between 55 and
70 55 and 65 an hour then you can start
doing packages and those packages like
Jackie did those will actually take you
higher and higher and actually add more
and more value but you've got to first
nail the foundation before you start
going all these fancy packages let's
take a couple more this might be a quick
one mica is wondering kind of creative
like a musician or actor use these same
three steps to generate leads for gigs
and landing movie roles yeah that's a
softball question yes no of course they
can it's a little more difficult because
entertainment has such a supply of
people who just will do anything for low
rates but there are certain techniques
you can use it we talked about today and
tomorrow about building relationships
and sidestepping the entire game what
else my hand raised over there do you
have this is from Derek do you have to
tell a story to convey emotion and in
return you're pitching a client almost
every time I didn't learn this for many
years but the power of narrative has
been incredibly strong we want a story
look at even products that shouldn't
have a story but do look at pick up the
book the power of habit and read the
chapter about Febreze and how that was
going to be a multi multi-million dollar
failure until they found that
it's not false it's true look at the
story of Listerine look at this very
well these classic commodity products
that actually sell five six ten times
the price and actually people experience
more value because of the narrative the
story and the narrative is absolutely
critical you don't just come to my site
see a list of products and then buy
something yeah I don't even put my
products on my site I don't even think
you can buy anything right now
because I want you to go through the
entire experience and so do I mean think
about the experience of walking into
Tiffany the jeweler versus somebody at
your mall you're gonna get champagne
you're gonna be pampered you're gonna
have a very sort of high-class person
probably a woman showing you around
really telling you what looks good also
saying you know I probably wouldn't do
that if I were you totally different
experience now are we all Tiffany no but
we are all trying to think about how to
add more value to our clients lives if
we do that and we do some other things
correctly then the money will come
advertising technology why why this well
I've seen you know a number of people
that I know closely follow our
advertising they absolutely love it and
I want to find something that I actually
can follow and love for my first career
okay good good better try this try this
you know how I actually I actually
thought about that a lot and when I was
first deciding where to work I looked at
both industries actually went out and
researched it with 10 or 20 people from
each industry but when it came down to
make the decision I thought back to when
I ran my Russian frat and actually the
head is like 25 people and one time we
had to figure out a way to generate 75
thousand dollars of revenue by next
Tuesday ok can you actually imagine
having to do that with a bunch of
college kids who don't even know what
they're doing so we actually ended up
using advertising to drive a ton of
revenue and we were able to send sixty
thousand dollars to the local charity
Hospital like to me that's when I
realized the power of advertising and
that's when I knew that I wanted to work
here and after I started doing my
research
Acme B was pretty much the only choice
well thank you very much but what what
did i do there right
the smile at the and I'm not a smiley
guy actually I told the creative life's
to have to remind me to smile because I
actually still find it a struggle to
smile a lot that's true but what did I
do with the smile what did you notice
when I was smiling it made it a lot
easier to have this conversation it
wasn't like an interview it was more
like that
just a conversation yeah and I
completely disarmed or you when you
smile completely disarmed me in fact you
almost short-circuited or logically not
actually but you almost short-circuited
when you smile that's why I said it
almost doesn't matter what you say
because when you smile you actually
connect on a totally different level and
you know who knows this really well
women because they smile naturally and
they stand they can see a reaction
instantly right they see things that men
don't see for a variety of biological
reasons and social reasons too so guys
and that's the reason that I want to
bring you up here it's yet one of the
things that really tests guys is body
language and body landed back our legs
are really spread and also just like
smiling
we're like masculine dudes and when I
talk about smiling it's kind of your
calling yeah it's kind of weird this is
like a little bit weird but actually
it's very important so I'm not saying
grin like this all the time I'm saying
use it strategically cuz what I did was
I took that smile who noticed what I did
with the smile I talked what did I do a
lot more in the first half than you did
in the second half and interestingly I
looked around the room we were all
smiling back watch you can't resist it
yeah you cannot resist smiling when
someone else smiles in a genuine way
what's that doing it's instantly making
you connect and Iceman out what should I
did I smile I said chill
it's funny you mention that and I said I
I was deciding between these two I
researched 20 people subtly showing that
I do a lot of work and then it and then
it made me remember back to my Russian
fret which I ran and we had to raise
$75,000 now it's like a pretty emotional
topic and then I made a quick little
g-rated joke can you imagine doing that
with a bunch of college kids and don't
know what they're doing and the guy's
like ah but it's not it's not a x-rated
joke it's a g-rated joke but we can all
agree haha that's funny
this guy has a sense of humor move on so
then I was like we had to raise $75,000
and this is how we did it and they
advertising I was able to give 60 K to
the hospital that was a nice little I
made that up but it became clear that
there was only one choice I mean the
guys like Jesus sign here's the offer
letter right now but but it's not just
what I said right and obviously I have a
lot of practice doing this we can all
get good really good but what I'm
highlighting here is the power of the
narrative you can brag about yourself
without bragging I bragged about my
accomplishments in a story right we're
gonna do one more question then we're
gonna wrap it it's it didn't seem like
bragging did it I mean a little bit I
probably come off a little bit more
let's say cocky then the average person
in the interview I I know that I
acknowledge it I have to consciously
work with that smile you know kind of
self-deprecating cuz I know myself other
people know that they come off as too
self-deprecating so they have to
actually pump it up so know yourself and
manage it are we gonna do a couple more
questions you wanted to we'll say this
is a tough one all right say uh so drew
what is your greatest weakness I would
say my greatest weakness is why I really
ought to think about that can I ask you
a question sure
off no how about it no okay all right
cool this is tough you can ask me a
question as your interviewer though okay
I would say my greatest weakness is
having having a tendency to do too much
and doing too much work you know there's
always a there's always a deadline and
there's always a amount of work you need
to do and sometimes I mean i surpass
that and do too much okay stop right
there who here believes that answer no
one you don't even believe it I know I
know I know okay so this is an answer
every single print now this is an answer
that everyone needs to be prepared to
answer a question need to be printed you
didn't believe it we knew you didn't
believe it we didn't
believe it so I want to highlight this
I'm not coming down on you at all
there's a tough question
if you [ __ ] your way through an
interview they will know an interviewer
is way more skilled than you he sees
more interviews than you can imagine in
a day so do not try to lie do not try to
take my dream job scripts and make them
your own if they're not true all right
the point of this is to make it your own
who here has a good weakness answer go
ahead
I've dealt a lot with being an over
communicator there are times that I
think it's important to give a lot of
information and there are times that I
think it's important to do your job and
deliver the deliverables cut the fat um
I've noticed that in myself and it's
something that I'm working towards and
I'm excited to deliver the optimal
amount of communication in our
relationship together what do you guys
think Wow applause I exactly pretty good
I'm gonna tweak that a little bit but
you actually followed the structure
almost perfectly what is okay what
people don't realize is when someone's
asking for your greatest weakness what
are they really asking they want to know
what your weakness is yes in fact every
interview question follows the same
pattern they want to know the answer to
the question but they want to know the
deeper answer they want to know your key
message okay so when I'm asking about
your weakness what I really want to know
is first of all that you're
knowledgeable enough to acknowledge that
you have a weakness everybody has
weaknesses top performers the best
people I know best people I know that
they are so candid about their
weaknesses they're like well you know
I'm actually I'm good at a couple things
but I'm pretty bad at a few things and
then they want to know that you are
self-aware enough to be working on them
to improve it now you just said you're
working to improve it but that's generic
you need to show me so let me try to say
that back to you okay once you ask me
you know the weakness question what is
your weakness well there's a lot but you
know one of the ones that I've really
noticed in the last few in the last
couple of years has been that I tend to
over communicate sometimes so for
example I might have
senior person like my senior manager of
my last company you might say listen I
need this thing by tomorrow and I will
ask him do you know I understand that
can I also add this can I also add that
what about this well you need this as
well and a couple of times I noticed him
being very Curt with me just saying look
just send it to me okay I have other
things to do and that was when I kind of
started paying attention to knowing when
to give the right amount of information
sometimes you actually need to send this
much sometimes you don't need to send
this much so a couple of things I did to
try to improve that one I actually went
to a Dale Carnegie Institute and I
attended that and that really helped me
learn XYZ and the other thing I've been
doing is just paying attention to the
senior people in my company really
studying how they communicate the emails
they send sometimes they're so short and
sometimes there's this long they
intuitively know how long to send and
I'm just learning that so it's something
that I'm definitely working on hopefully
in the cover letter and resumes and
emails we've exchanged you see that it's
something that I'm certainly trying to
improve on okay so you know you don't
have to applaud me this is what I do for
a living all right so don't interview me
all right so so I think I actually
messed up at the beginning I said there
are so many that was just nervousness I
don't need to say that that's
self-deprecating why don't this is an
interview this is not mr. Amit's
eighties therapy session all right so I
overdid that that was not good I thought
the rest of it was good but I thought it
could be improved it was a little long
what do you guys think what what did you
notice in that answer when you ask this
question you're establishing three
really clear facts in the candidate are
they self aware do they know themselves
strengths weaknesses secondly are are
they can they be proactive once they
identify it are they do they crumble
when there's a mistake or are they
willing to take action and fix it and I
forgot the third is that I think
especially younger people write drew
when things happen to us at work that
are negative like the terse emails how
many you know how many of us just like
sit around and [ __ ] about it and are
like this person's tears to me you know
this sucks this company's
you know I liked what you did where you
said I noticed that this was happening
and I looked internally for the answer
yeah
taking responsibility super high
competence trigger top performers always
do that always they they're like look I
could blame a million people but there's
one person I can blame well go to the
web in one second but on the key thing
the key thing I I did there that nobody
quite picked up on was I told the story
you cannot stop listening to an engaging
story humans physically cannot stop
listening to an engaging story
I took you along that path with me and
at each point just as I did in the
earlier one with the frat you couldn't
stop listening now the story wasn't dad
interesting really I had a frat 75k I
mean whatever but I had pauses it got
emotional we talk same thing here I took
a Dale Carnegie Institute by the way
that brought down the house in this room
everyone was like Jesus this guy just
how did he do that like I made it up I
made it up so it's easy to make it up on
the spot right it's easy with a lot of
practice but what could you do to
address your biggest weakness everyone
right now you know that you're going to
be asked in an interview what is your
greatest weakness so what are you doing
proactively to fix it you could do you
couldn't take a Dale Carnegie Institute
class all right you could take this
class you could buy the recording of
this class and watch it and practice it
again and again okay so there are many
things you can do or you can sit around
and do nothing and be unprepared for the
question so main points there were the
store we're gonna do one last question
the main points there were the story I
told the story and you came along for
the ride and I wrapped it up with a tidy
bow at the end something you will learn
with practice okay last question you
know do I've really enjoyed talking you
today but I'm gonna be totally candid
with you I have a lot of applicants
there's some people who have more
experience than you there's some people
who they may have a better GPA than you
why should I choose you
well I'm you know in college it would
take me it would be easy for me to help
out my friends because I would learn
things quickly over the other candidates
you know I think I stand out because of
fact you know I'm losing it right now
okay pletely train okay pick it from the
top why should I choose you okay I stand
out because I'm very quickly other
people may have a better GPA and other
people may be more qualified but I think
that since I'm a quick learner
I can I can come in and I can really get
a hold of things quickly I can learn but
I need to learn I can give you what you
need okay all right
thoughts how'd you feel saying that not
great okay why I have no idea but it
just didn't feel good it didn't feel
right you ended on like kind of a dot
dot dot right one thing I learned from
my mentor BJ Fogg he said at the end of
a presentation you know some experts say
don't say thank you because the audience
should be thanking you whatever he's
like and on a strong note I learned this
with a lot of practice you'll notice
every professional goes on TV they
always say data data and data and that's
why I did that at a DA it's like a song
almost so but you didn't know where you
were going so kind of just dragged off
at the very least you can restate the
question you can say you know so that's
that's why you know I think that I stand
out among my peers or something like
that
anybody else notice anything here
there's a tough question for this type
of question because it's such I've asked
you so many broad questions
these are intentionally really tough I
said like tell me about yourself oh my
god you could go in a million different
directions right but there are
frameworks you can apply to each of
these questions where it's almost like
this is what happens when I started
getting really good at this they would
ask the question and I would instantly
see the map in my head you guys remember
that movie with Nash the mathematician
movie right and he sees those things it
wasn't like that I'm not that cool but
it wasn't actually anything at all like
that but I knew that I had I knew the
type of question he was going to ask
because I'd seen it because I'd done a
lot of interviews I also knew that I had
a bunch of stories right here in my back
pocket and my quiver write my story
toolbox it just came together I also use
certain techniques like I have a little
a couple of fillers that I can use the
beginning while my mind ramps up and
then it all comes together again this
happens with practice so can I take a
crack at that
ask me the question well why should I
choose why should why should I choose
you well that's a that's a really tough
question but I think a really fair
question candidly you probably have a
lot of people with more experience than
me so why would you choose someone who's
relatively inexperienced but the way I
think about it I think about it in three
different ways the first one is you know
a demonstrated interest in advertising
so I didn't just choose to interview
with you because I had nothing else to
do if you actually look I ran the
advertising Club in college I actually
applied some of that by running the
Russian frat and using that to generate
$60,000 and donate it this is something
that I've been fascinated in both on a
practical level and even on an academic
level attending conferences about
advertising things like that the second
thing is the second thing is
oh it's actually slipping my mouth
excuse me the second thing is that I
want to take what I've done and apply it
to a larger stage so I've been working
you know in a small level at a college
level
etc but now I want to take it to a
bigger league and then that leads
naturally to the third one which is I
like you and like anyone want to work
with the best so we all know that acne
is the best I'm not just saying that to
butter you up the things you've done in
terms of the XYZ campaign and the ABC
campaign those are things I studied
those are things I think that I could
contribute to but I also know that I
have a lot to learn so yes there may be
people who have more experience than me
but I think if you actually consider all
the things on balance the demonstrated
track record wanting to take it to a
bigger stage and also you know knowing
that I can contribute so much and also
learn from you then that is the reason
that I would actually select me okay so
I actually did you notice how I messed
up in the middle my brain just went boom
that was real I actually couldn't think
of it I was real I didn't mess up on
purpose
I'm trying to make this flawless let's
edit that out please actually I did mess
up my brain went blank because I wanted
to take the the smaller stage to the
larger stage I wanted to make that the
third one the crescendo and then I
couldn't think of the second one so I
was like oh [ __ ] so I put that as a
second and then I came up with a third
one as I was doing the second
okay it seems like black magic right now
because you're like how is this guy
doing all this stuff whatever but this
is just practice practice practice
imagine you break it down you you start
to interview you start to answer
interview questions you start to see the
same questions over and over you're
testing your answers you know the
questions are gonna ask you know the
words they want to hear and use you get
so good at this that you can answer
almost anything you see why I said that
my dream job students they could take my
scripts and they can probably get a
second round interview but the top
students actually know how to
internalize it they can take and parry
and genuinely answer virtually any
question so does that make sense to you
what would you take away from this
exercise in terms of your interviewing
well I know that I need to sit down and
actually think of the questions and yeah
think of my answers uh-huh and more
importantly I need to be able to come up
with relatable things stories from my
backgrounds and at least concrete
examples from things I've done yeah and
be able to relate those not just to you
at the end of your company in school
awesome job amazing so anyone else
totally impressed by drew like first of
all just the fact to get up on stage is
incredible that is ballsy and then the
answers for never really having done a
mock interview is that your first time
and I've done that's incredible really
really great stuff it shows you that
with just a little bit of practice you
can you know you can take those answers
and in fact he did that on the first one
he took an answer that was a bit
rambling he made it really good imagine
if you do that 5 or 10 times just 5 or
10 times in your life how much better
would you be than everyone else
incredible that's how my students go on
to get $20,000 raises $30,000 new jobs
it's not because they're the biggest
geniuses in the world they understood
the systematic process and they actually
put in the work and went through it
anybody have any reactions questions
comments on that and then we're gonna
ask one of my students Robert to come
out in just a cup in just a few minutes
reactions from here and reactions from
the web what do we have from here
anybody if that was the only other done
one other interview and you were like
with him of all people with this
audience talking about I mean it's like
that is insanely impressive that you
were that calm and did that well okay if
I really hope that you feel that and
take that confidence with you because I
couldn't have done that I don't think a
lot of people watching could have done
that so the Internet as well drew folks
are saying awesome drew I was sweating
bullets just watching you yeah great job
drew did it great he was so calm yeah
that gave me anxiety watching
good job drew oh yeah Jinja drew slipped
me a 20 before so he could do a little
singles exercise up here oh alright
alright so so hope I do have a question
okay people were asking about how you
can practice this sort of oh great so
Toastmasters people were bringing out
their coffee chats or very simple
there's there's a two or three stages to
it the first is you actually write down
the questions that you're gonna get you
can predict 80% of the questions just on
the top of your head and if you don't
know go to google and search for common
interview questions five minutes okay
this is the laziest thing people do they
walk into an interview and they're
surprised I'm like you're surprised they
asked you the questions that everyone
asks alright so you can predict those
the second thing is so you can write
your answers for them literally script
them out then you can start saying them
I actually just say them out loud and
people like oh my god that's so weird to
say it out loud in front of a mirror I
actually think it's weird to be losing
50 a hundred three hundred thousand
dollars over your lifetime because you
were unwilling to do this for one
weekend then what you do is you call up
on your friends who's pretty good at
this kind of stuff they don't have to be
a master interviewer they just have a
good job you say listen would you be
willing to interview me and give me some
feedback they'll come over on a Saturday
they'll ask you this the final stage is
to videotape yourself then you tape this
interaction this is really scary I'll
tell you I went on TV I went on a lot of
places before I went on book tour and I
told my publisher will you guys get me
media training they're like why we think
you're really good we've seen you on TV
I was like
in my head I was like oh cuz you're
gonna pay for it but I told them like I
want to perfect my craft so they sent me
to media training and media training was
really good
they took my book she had read it and
she said and this was clarity Media
Group by the way I'm happy to promote
them they the lady who was there was
terrific
she asked me some questions that I would
get on a TV show and they videotaped my
answers and I thought I was so savvy and
I watched the videotape and I was like
oh my god I hate this guy
I hate me I hated myself and we did it
over and over and over again in one
afternoon and I became much crisper and
able to anticipate and wrap it up so
right now if the cameraman tells me like
wrap it up I can wrap it up right now or
if I need to stretch it out 20 minutes I
could do that too just a lot of practice
so that's how I would do this hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat number one
is perhaps my favorite audiobook of all
time and that is the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman the only audiobook I've
wanted to immediately listen to a second
time as soon as I finished it's amazing
you will
thank me the graveyard book the second
is vagabonding Bhairav pots which had a
huge impact on my life
and formed the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free 30-day trial
is go to audible.com forward slash Tim
and you can choose one of those two
books the graveyard book vagabonding or
more than 180,000 audio programs so that
could be a book that could be a magazine
that can be a newspaper it could be a
class it's that easy go to audible.com
forward slash Tim that's audible.com
forward slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
this podcast is brought to you by trunk
club I hate shopping with a passion and
you guys know this and I'm honestly not
any good at it anyway which means I end
up looking like I'm colorblind or
homeless this is where trunk Club comes
in which provides you with your own
personal stylist and makes it easier
than ever to shop for clothes that look
great on your body even if you suck at
picking clothing just go to trunk club
comm forward slash Tim and answer a few
questions and then you'll be sent a
trunk full of awesome clothes they base
this on your sizes preferences all that
jazz the trunk is then delivered free of
charge both ways so you only pay for
clothes that you keep so you have
prepaid stickers and whatnot if you keep
none it costs you nothing it's super
easy trunk Club is not a subscription
service which I wanted to avoid there
are no monthly fees also wanted to avoid
that your stylist is free shipping is
always free and you have ten days to try
on the clothes risk-free and trunk club
is backed by Nordstrom which means they
have the highest standards and quality
and customer service if you care about
saving time or looking good
check it out at rump club.com forward
slash Tim again that's truck club.com
forward slash Tim